gary had a romantic valentine's day he
drove his wife to a sunset somewhere
like yeah i know it seems like a lot of
work but
what did you do again we went to
tarrytown there's a big parking lot
where you get a big view of the tappan
zee bridge
yeah in the water and the sunset so we
drove there there wasn't even a sunset
that night we just watched it get dark
and the
bridge light up and then we we bought a
burgers from the rest of the restaurant
we ate them in the car
then we drove home uh was there anybody
else there
shockingly robin there was apparently
this is the thing there were at least
15 other cars there i don't know why i
think that's dumb
and i have no right to say that because
by the way tappan zee bridge is a
beautiful [ __ ] accomplishment it's a
beautiful architectural structure it
really is
by the way it's not the tappan zee
bridge it's the mario cuomo bridge now
that's right oh is it on india that's
right
oh i'm gary puppet hello and while we're
eating our burgers
i was playing my soundtrack i made a
list of my favorite love
songs i love love is blue by paul
marriott
love by nat king cole all you need is
love by the
beatles love me tender elvis also backed
up with burning love by elvis
i will always love you whitney houston
the theme to love
story by francis li when a man loves a
woman
by person sledge and of course it
wouldn't be
complete without i love rock and roll by
joan jett
i mean i was gonna goof on gary for
driving his wife to tarrytown to look at
the bridge
it just you know in my mind it seems
like a lot of
[ __ ] work we had to get out of the
house howard i really that's really what
it was
let's go to the kosciuszko bridge for
dessert
i can't imagine getting in my car with
my wife and staring
at the tappan zee bridge i just can't
imagine it it's just beyond my
imagination
it wasn't even that fun but when we got
home we're like okay that was something
that was something but there's so many
better somethings
i could have told you stay in your house
and and listen to your vinyl or
did you just trampoline by the way did
you i did not
no i didn't at least that would have
been something
he created i mean i don't know but to
sit
in a car and stare at the tap like
gary's
just i don't i mean i love him to death
but i don't get him i don't
get it next weekend we have something
really big planned i'm gonna
drive her to the queen's midtown tunnel
and she's gonna give me a handgun